[Music]  we are leading the way in the greatest  human advancement of all time  the technology running through his veins  augments his strength his reflexes even  his healing capabilities  he's unlike anything we've seen before  [Music]  and he's entirely in our control  commencing memory fabrication next  mission in three two one  and initiate sequence  what am I doing here you've got yourself  killed  [Music]  you have bacon on the second chance  you have an army inside you I call them  nice they rebuilt you those are in my  blood  there are your blood welcome to your  future  I have a mecha  [Music]  right  I've been replied  [Music]  what you think is real sometimes ain't I  had a wife into trouble for me  into a weapon  they're getting Kenny no chance  oh man  [Music]  [Music]